retrouver au bonheur des livres avec le
Centre national du
[Musique]
livre voilà bonjour Au Bonheur des
livres avec y Kenel l'un des meilleurs
écrivains français qui publie cette
fois-ci un livre dans une collection qui
maintenant fait parler d'elle ma nuit au
musée chez Stock un bleu bacon donc il
s'agit d'une nuit passée par Yannick
justement au Centre Pompidou au cœur
d'une rétrospective consacrée à Francis
Bacon le grand peintre anglais qu'il est
pratiquement inutile de présenter Miguel
Barcelo et lui tout simplement un des
plus grands peintres européens il est
aussi un acteur justement de ce qu'a été
la vie au fond des arts plastique ces 40
dernières années hein migel puisque vous
avez été le contemporain de basquat
quand il était vivant rencontrer handy
warol vécu avec vos amis espagnols et
puis pour échapper à cette vie
dangereuse vous tes aller vous réfugier
en Afrique vous travaillez évidemment à
Paris vous travaillez à maork qui est
aussi évidemment votre ville de
naissance et le livre s'appelle de la
vida Mia c'est trèit et prait Mercure de
France alors ça se présente comme une
sorte de carnet de bord d'une vie avec à
la fois des tableaux en voici un on va
demander à la réalisation donc assez
des croquis des
textes une histoire que vous racontez
celle d'une mère que vous adorez qui est
encore là d'un papa avec qui les
rapports ont été difficiles et des
débuts dans la peinture qui ont été
quasi immédiats migel oui mais je suis
né dans une maison où il y avait de la
peinture comme il y a des gens qui nai
dans une maison où il y a des jeux
d'échèque ou de ou de des collection de
de tambbre poste chez moi il y avait de
tubes à huile et de livres de peinture
et des tableau de tableau mon mon
grand-père avait des amis peintes entre
guerre disons et j'étais comme un petit
sang j'ai appris à peindre très vite et
je partais peindre avec ma mère ou avec
des amis de ma mère à la la campagne de
peinture au pleinir moi j'ai appelé ça
paste impressionisme parce que c'était
une variété de pâtisserie c'était de
comme de grotesques non et beaucoup de
ces P il peignaient avec plein tubes ça
faisait comme de et major que c'est une
plein de grottes et de grottes
sous-marines alors c'est t rassem
beaucoup à àe alors bon mon éducation
était un peu paradoxale parce qu'ensuite
à l'école de bazard tout l'école de
beauard de maorque après il y a eu celle
de Barcelone mais ça vous a Barbé très
vite vous arrêé une semaine oui c'est
carrément très très vite alors oui
c'était rapide mon mon le directeur de
mon école disait que j'avais été son
meilleur élève et j'ai dit j'étais
qu'une semaine il m'a dit oui mais vous
avait bien profité du temps c'est que
c'était probablement vrai oui et puis
après donc des expositions à Toulouse
pour commencer les exppositions en
Espagne après une visite à Miro donc les
grands peintres espagnols après donc une
carrière Yannick vous connaît très bien
il faut le dire qui explose dans le
monde entier il a exposé chez Castelli
il a explosé dans les plus grands musées
du monde il a exposé chez Yvon Lambert à
Paris chez Bruno bichof berger en Suisse
une vie donc aujourd'hui qui est à Paris
et à maork essentiellement mais une vie
un peu tumultueuse à New York vous avez
donc voyez Jean-Michel basqu dit warol
et les autres warol a même fait votre
portrait et c'est ça qui vous a poussé
vers l'Afrique au fond pour échapper à
la mort d'une certaine manière ouais
c'està qu'à l'époque c'était très lesjà
mourit comme de mche ouais vous dites
dans le livre d'ailleurs que tous vos
amis peintres artistes par les même derv
Gubert qui vous photographi Enya ils
sont tous Mor entre 27 et 33 ans entre
les Sid et les drogues et tout ça cette
génération c'est un peu comme si on
avait fait la guerre de 14-1 c'était un
peu cet effit là c'était oui terrible
est-ce que c'est ça qui vous a poussé
vers le Mali bah je sais pas peut-être
instantivement mais je pense qu'on a un
instant de survie non ça a dû être et
puis je suis allé à Mali pour un peu me
guérir de de la bêtise aussi non parce
que finalement pour savoir pourquoi je
sais pas je suis allé au Mali parce que
j'aimais bien au début je savais même
pas où j'allais et finalement après j'ai
m tellement que j'ai commencé à
apprendre à lire des choses sur les sur
les h et puis c'est plus tard que je
suis devenu vraiment
euh je savais où j'étais au début
j'allais au désert je savais même vous
êtes parti au début avec des amis
espagnols je suis parti avec des amis au
désert sans savoir très bien où j'allais
j'étais entre l'Algérie et les Mali mais
c'est seulement après que j'ai compris
que à quel point c'est une culture
profonde et puis ça et puis je voyais
que toutes mes objets devenaient
vieillissé au Mali les les livres son le
termite mange tout est couvert de même
son en plastique c'est desagrèg et moi
je rajenise ça me fais l'ffet contraire
non c'est et puis je me je me disais bon
je vaux mieux quand je rentre que quand
j'arrive j'ai arrivais en mauvais état
et je repartais tout alors alors que la
vie est quand même dangereuse là-bas
parce que au fond sur le plan médical si
jamais vous avez le moindre pépin je
crois que vous avez été piqué par un
scorpion à l'œil donc évidemment piqué
par un scorpion à l'œil ça fait très mal
mais c'est très dangereux B j'avais
j'avais les Garau h et j'avais une autre
chose qui son coupe et on sort le poison
mais aucune de ces techniques marchait
avec une picurelle alors j'ai dû
supporter mon
douleur comment vous avez construit le
livre migel Marcello parce que
évidemment votre est frisonnante là il y
a à la fois des aquarelles des dessins
un un portrait de méenes qui un grand
peintre espagnol donc de nature morte
dont vous dites que il peint comme Ozou
film c'est avec la caméra très très bas
et très proche des objets i oui oui oui
et vou être en pintre de rois en pintre
de figure et il a dû pendre des objets
toute sa vie alors avec une grande
frustration mais c'est un c'est un il se
révit en véasquez et en fait il s'est
occupé de pommes de poire d'abricot mais
si si vous regardez chaque pomme comme
si c'était une figure on comprend que en
bas souvent sous C tableau souvent il il
faisait un portrait du roi pour
présenter à
la cour et comme on lui disait non sur
ce tableau il il peignait ses ces Natur
mortes alors quand on fait des rayonit
on voit apparaître les figures en bas de
ces en bas de ses pommes et de ces poir
oui c'est une histoire curieuse j'ai
écrit ici que chaque fois tout les table
il y a une bord de table tout droit
comme ça et plus la vie avance plus ce
bord de table est cassé et je pense
chaque fois qu'il y avait un refus qui
avait une frustration ou une misère dans
sa vie il faisait une entaille dans ce
bord de table comme on dit d que B de
kit faisait dans son pistolet chaque
fois qu' tuis quelqu'un non il faisait
une marque je pense que de fait la même
chose et à la fin c'est un vrai sicsac h
il y a une chose qui est aussi
passionnante dans ce livre qui est très
bien accueilli par la critique c'est que
une grande partie de ceux qui font de la
peinture je parle pas de l'art
conceptuel je parle pas de l'art minimal
et cetera on l'impression par exemple
c'est ce qu'avait exprimé John Mitchell
et plein d'autres qu'au fond ils font de
la peinture pour échapper au mots pour
échapper à la littérature pour échapper
hi mais qu'il y a là une sorte de
réconciliation parce fait c'est un livre
il y a des textes et il y a toutes les
formes possibles d'expression artistique
oui moi j'aime beaucoup les mots et je
passe beaucoup de temps livre m'ont
accompagné toute ma vie c'est au Mali
j'avais que des livres et des peintures
je veux dire je peux pas vivre sans
livre c'est et pu je déteste pas
mémorialiste je déteste les mauvais
mémorialistes ah vous l'avez écrit oui
non mais chatau Bran j'aime beaucoup par
exemple pas oui oui non mais c'est pas
c'est pas que je déteste les genres mais
je voulais pas me mettre à faire mes
mémoires de à la con c'est mais j'aime
beaucoup les journaux les journal de la
croix par exemple c'est excellent non et
c'est c'est pas prétentieux c'est écrit
d'une manière très qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de cette période justement euh
puisque maintenant que cette carrière se
développe et vous êtes une certaine
manière maintenant enfin tout le monde
le sait reconnu mond entier mais de
cette un peu dingue justement fin boirol
début basquia la fin vous en retenez
quoi aujourd'hui est que cette période
est devenue un peu mythique pour tout le
monde c'est-à-dire moi je pense qu'on
vivait moment de post-modernisme et le
post-modernisme c'était un peu la
conséquence deart et de de de la et puis
de la on croyait plus comment dire moi
j'ai jamais été communiste par exemple
loin de là j'avis une grande méfiance de
tous ces mais des gens plus âgés que moi
ils venaient ils étaient des gens de
parti ils parlaient avec des termes
marxistes ou militaires les avantgardes
c'était des termes militaires non comme
et et puis les post-modern on on on a
refusé tout ça on pillait l'histoire de
l'art comme de pirates qui arrivent dans
une ville il prend
tout moi je prenais oui oui bien sûr
envie de pendre et on disait c'est
interdit la perspective comment c'est
interdit la perspective j'ai fouté des
perspectives trois ou quatre dans chaque
tableau pour faire et puis c'est
postmodernisme c'est un grand souffle de
liberté en peinture en tout cas le le
livre en est la trace il y a aussi la
trace des parents avec un père avec qui
vous entendez vous dites vous-même pas
très bien et puis de très nombreux
textes al le charme du livre c'est
justement qu'il y ait on va parler
maintenant d' Yan Kenel de Béconne et on
se retrouve ensemble par exemple là vous
avez une une photo par
exemple ouais de l'atelier donc dans le
Marat de Miguel barelo vous voyez à quel
point
justement la peinture non seulement est
envahissante mais est présente partout
dans le bon sens du terme migel peint
plusieurs tableaux repeint revient sur
les tableaux qu'il a oublié passe au
dessin passe à la gravure illustre des
livres d'écrivain célèbres et donc
maintenant sort ce livre de la vie
d'Amia que vous allez lire qui est sorti
donc au Mercure de France vous restez
avec nous mon cher Miguel parce que nous
allons parler aussi d'un livre que vous
avez lu qui est celui de Yannick Enel
bleu bacon alors Yannick donc grand
écrivain je le disais passionné par la
peinture comme un peu son celui qui qui
a été pendant longtemps son compagnon et
une sorte de paèire spirituelle qui est
Philippe Solers et voici qui arrive donc
bacon il s'agit d'une rétrospective
bacon qui a lu en Angleterre qui passa
un peu partout qui arrive au centre
Pidou et on vous propose avec le
conservateur de passer une nuit au musée
au milieu de ces
tableaux deux ou trois tableaux vont
retenir votre votre attention plus
particulièrement le fameux dip et le
Sphinx app dans un instant les
triptiques qui vous font peur et au
départ alors c'est ça où c'est très
romancé d'une certaine manière c'est que
au moment où il entre dans ces h salles
je crois vous êtes pris par une espèce
de migraine épouvantable qui vous oblige
à vous scotcher sur le lit de camp qu'on
vous a pré de prendre du tramadol comme
un malade plutôt que de faire un travail
de réflexion sur les œuvres qu'on vous
présente c'est-à-dire que je les voyais
plus les œuvres avec à la fois les les
néons puis les vitres que que derrière
lesquelles Béon enferme sa peinture il y
avait des des refle cass00 qui m'ont
cisaillé les yeux ça m'a fait monter une
migraine ophthalmique tout de suite je
voyais plus rien mais et 30 secondes
avant avec le patron de beauourg vous
étiez tout à fait tranquille r
exactement mais c'est l'impact c'est la
sorcellerie blanche je crois que Miguel
aussi c'est un sorcier c'est un poète et
un sorcier la sorcellerie blanche ou
parfois noire de Béon ça agit tout de
suite moi j'étais en fait j'étais très
content d'avoir un mal de chien à la
tête parce que je me disais ça y est ça
agit tout de suite la peinture j'étais
venu chercher ça me rendre DISP ça
durait toute la nuit c'était cuit
j'étais foutu parce que en plus bah déjà
c'est une grande douleur je voyais je
voyais plus très bien et puis j'ai pris
double dose de tramadol et je c'est un
enti douleur qui est pas très loin de la
morphine voilà et j'ai eu une espèce
d'extase vous êtes réveillé très bien je
me suis réveillé parfaitement parce que
j'étais sous un tableau de bacon que
j'adore que j'ai mis en alors on va le
montrer
hein water from running T et en fait
c'est la c'est une dimension de bacon
que j'ignorais enfin que je connaissais
moins c'est la la jouvant
un tableau à moitié peint sur une toile
qui est à moitié vierge exactement puce
qu'il retourne ces toiles voilà avec
quelques chose qui est d'abord peint à
l'aérosol et qui est à peu près complété
et qui n'est pas du tout la mise en
scène de la souffrance habituelle
exactement il y a pas de corps qui se
contorsionne il y a pas de cage il y a
pas de Pape donc les trois grandes
choses qu'on reti y a pas la il y a pas
la MAN et il y a de l'eau
crémeuse avec différents bleus qui se
qui s'entre relass et du et du rose le
rose et le bleu quasi couleur de layette
couleur de de de bébé presque et d'avoir
passé 2hures à peu près sous ce tableau
sans bien m'en rendre compte je pense
que ça ça ça m'a fait du bien il a
veillé sur moi ce tableau après m'avoir
fait tomber bcon m'a m'a pris dans ses
bras et je suis allé comme un comme un
personnage de du Caravage comme un
jean-baptistequ vous avez écrit j'ai
écrit un livre il y a longtemps voilà
sur le Caravage et je suis allé vers le
robinet mais je vous assure comme si
c'était une fontaine je suis allé boire
la peinture et durant les 10h que j'ai
passé tout seul une chance inouie en
fait d'être tout seul à à beauourg comme
ça vous allez plus loin parce que je
sais pas si Miguel partage on en parlera
tout à l'heure cet avis au fond vous
dites il y a une sorte de non pas des
scroqueries muséal mais au fond les
tableaux ne sont faits que pour être vu
seul ouais c'est pas l'escroquerie je
pense que tout le monde il font ce qu'il
peuvent mais mais mais le rapport
initiatique ça dépense cherche moi je
cherche avec les tableaux quelque chose
d'un peu doromachique justement
d'initiation domachique c'est la grande
spécialité de ah oui de bacon moi moi
j'aime dans le livre de de Miguel aussi
so soit une initiation on s'initie au
fait même de vivre et là je voulais en
fait en fait j'ai traversé ma propre
nuit et toute mon existence s'est revécu
grâce aux couleurs alors parfois de la
souffrance de l'angoisse parfois une
jubilation folle de l'euphorie et c'est
ce c'est ce truc là cette ambivalence
qui est très belle avec la peinture
quand on Bécon il faut donner deux ou
trois mots autobiographiques il né en
Irlande il est homosexuel son père qui
est un militaire comme vous votre père
était militaire le confie à une sorte de
protecteur à Londres en considérant
qu'il va le ramener dans dans le droit
chemin en fait le type est un serérial
fucker c'est pire que tout il l'emmènera
à Berlin donc à la grande époque il va à
Monaco et alors là où c'est une des
grandes caractéristiques par rapport à
Picasso par rapport à Matis et même si
les études ont été très breeves de de
mckel à Barcelone c'est un autodidacte
total il n'a jamais rien appris il est
rentré à Londres et il s'est mis à à
peindre Francis Bécon et vous tombez
deuxème tableau donc on imagine Yanni
Kenel sortant de son lit avec le
tramadol regardant donc le premier
tableau sur odip et le Sphinx qui n'est
pas un tableau à priori comique puisque
odip souffre tout le monde connaît ce
myth sauf que vous poussez un éclairir
phénoménal ah j'étais dans un état
tramadol ou c'est le le bacon ouais les
deux mais je pense que je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose de de comique dans dans
ce tableau secrètement peut-être parce
que odip c'est sur fond rose et odip qui
est sur la gauche face à la sphinge odip
lève son pied bandé et euh donc un grand
bandage blanc du sang avec un petit
prisme bleu et il est surtout en short
et Marcel il a l'air d'une espèce de
sportif un peu nularard et ça me fait
rire d'ailleurs parce que le T le
tableau appartient à syvester Stalone
donc je riais aussi en me disant Rocky
tous les matins voit ce tableau dans son
chez lui c'est merveille et bon il se
trouve que il se trouve que bah j'ai
l'impression que Bacon règle son compte
avec od diip disant mais pauvre dip tu
es vraiment rien la singe elle c'est
quelqu'un alors le le le sing qu'il faut
il est un peu masqué comme ça tendu
comme si c'était justement quelqu'un qui
arrivait à un braqueur dans une nuit au
au musée un dernier point avant qu'on
Converse ensemble parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de chos à raconter sur la
carrière de Michel et sur bacon et sur
les rapports entre les grands peintres
entre eux parce qu'au fond c'est un
dialogueou permanent c'est il y a quand
même une partie de l'œuvre de bacon qui
est une œuvre qui au départ vous
terrorisit un peu notamment le fameux
triptique on voit cette espèce de long
coup d'animal préhistorique qui se
termine par une mâchoire terrible ou oui
les trois les trois les trois monstres
moi je les appelais les serpentsou la
première fois que j'ai vu un tableau de
bacon je crois que c'était la Tate
briton adolescent j'ai été épouvanté je
suis sorti en courant du voyez ça agit
vraiment et cette nuit-là je m'étais
j'avais donné rendez-vous mentalement
avec ce tableau dont il y avait une
bacon parfois repeigné enfin une
deuxième version et et ça a été un une
épreuve aussi que de que d'arriver à le
regarder et à et à vaincre mes peurs et
puis j'avais demandé à j'avais demandé
aux pompiers à ce qu'ils éteignent les
lumières aussi parce que j'ai j'ai
l'obsession comme Miguel des grottes et
j'avais j'avais acheté une lampe torche
et donc la dernière partie de la nuit
j'étais tout seul en train de d'envoyer
de la lumière sur les tableaux c'était
absolument merveilleux voilà deux livres
au programme de bonheur des livres celui
de Michel Barcello don grand peintre de
la vida Mia qui est publié au Mercure de
France dors déjà grand succès comme
celui d' Yannick kel bleu bacon c'est la
collection ma nuit au musée yannique
vous a raconté tout à l'heure dans
quelles circonstances il s'est retrouvé
donc pendant toute une nuit au musée
alors d'une rétrospective bacon question
Miguel quel rapport on parlit tout à
l'heure de Mélen des donc des peint
historique quel rapport vous entretenez
avec vos grands aînés a par exemple avec
Francis Bacon David ocney Guard trichter
l'allemand ave bacon d'admiration et je
les croisé j'ai jamais parlé avec lui
mais je les croisé deux ou trois fois
ici et là et je sais qu'il est allé voir
mes tableaux al j'étais toujours très
content mais avec la peinture on toute
peinture est toujours contemporaine
c'est-à-dire j'ai le même rapport avec
le tableau de bacon qu'avec l'artiste de
la grotte Chauvé pas de progrès en fait
il y a pas de progème tout est
contemporaine et ont fait l'art pour les
mêmes raisons c'est et puis quand tu vas
à la GR tu reconnais la main tu
reconnais c'est mon frère c'est c'est
c'est cet homme et Yannick il y a une
chose que que les gens qui connaissent
l'histoire de l'art savent mais que vous
reprécisez c'est que dans le casad de
bacon la vision des autres qu'évoquait
tout à l'heure Miguel Barcelo est très
importante notamment la vision de
Picasso parce que évidemment quand il
voit Picasso chez Paul rosimbert le
marchand ou quand il le voit au musée il
voit comme une autorisation de détruire
les visages qui lui est donné par
quelqu'un d'autre qui n'avait peut-être
pas envisagé absolument mais je crois
que je crois que
Bacon jamais caché qu'effectivement
c'était c'est Picasso qui lui a donné la
clé d'ailleurs c'était des des petites
peintures à Dinard les années 20 où euh
Picasso se cachait dans les cabines de
bain avec sa très jeune amante et donc
il y a ces histoires de clés comme ça et
bacon va mettre un pied qui ouvre les
clés c'est très mystérieux en fait ILM
oui mais c'est tableau très précis c'est
sur des tableau précis de Picasso des
tableau avec de rondeur non c'est ça qui
fait qui fait son beigneus ou les fameus
oui oui oui et des table de voyurs oui
comment se fait-il que l'Espagne soit
peut-être le plus grand alors c'est le
point de vue de Picasso parce que
Picasso a quand même il a écrit sur le
Caravage je parle de Yannick Picasso
détestait le Caravage Yannick adore
Bonard Picasso disait disait non Picasso
disait Bonard est un con on lui montre
le soleil
oui mais mais Picasso aller voir les SP
de Bonard de ou trois fois en cachette
il faut pas toujours croire ce qu'on dit
les peintres il faut croire ce qu' on
fait VO l' malicieux oui non mais parce
que Picasso disait que Bonard était
uncetable mais après il allait voir son
ESPO plusieurs fois et puis il disait
que Tintoretto c'était de de de mais il
aimait pas la naissance oui mais il
disait que les grand serpent de son
espagnol mais c'est pas les pintes ils
ont pas de pays tout tout pinté de
partout moi je suis autant italien que
français que tout ça c'est après bien
sûr on veut voir on veut voir l'Irlande
dans bacon
l'Espagne noire dans dans dans pourquoi
pas mais ça ça marcherait bien si on
changeait tous ces figures de la crèche
de place ça serait pareil tu vois Goya
comme un peintre français ça marcherait
parfaitement
bien Goya d'ailleurs il faut le rappeler
qui a été pu que l'histoire de la
postérité est toujours une histoire
importante Goya qui a été ignoré pendant
pratiquement de oui oui oui comme Greco
Greco a été ignoré plus que ça 4 non 4
siècl et puis est devenu une évidence ça
ça arrive tout les temps ça j'ai une
grande question pour vous donc Miguel
maork Paris et malheureusement à cause
de l'actualité terroriste a été obligé
d'abandonner son atelier donc du côté de
Gao Mali je sais que vous avez beaucoup
vécu en Afrique donc ça vous rapproche
vous avez écrit un article dans
charlibdo élogieux sur le livre de
Miguel mais il y a cette question aussi
de la violence chez bacon parce qu'on a
beaucoup expliqué que Bacon c'était
alcool les bars euh euh un rapport qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs chez pas mal de
peintres anglais avec en gros les
dockers les ouvriers enfin c'est pas la
sexualité banale d'une homosexualité
mondaine il y a quelque chose de violent
qu'on retrouve dans les tableaux et
quand il a eu sa première grande
rétrospective à Paris son amant George
der meurt et silence il dit pas un mot
la souffrance est considérable mais
l'apparence est est respectée et il
accepte justement cette
rétrospective comment on peut expliquer
ça je crois que che chez cette violence
dominée ou cette souffrance dominée
qu'on voit sur les tableaux partout mais
c'est exactement c'est c'est c'est le
point secret c'est le point qu'and
descend bacon c'est c'est de parvenir à
à contrôler sa violence enfin d'après ce
qu'on sait il il buvait énormément la
nuit enfin mais de manière à éthique il
allait directement à son atelier à 6h du
matin il peignait dans un état qui
n'était sans doute pas un état de rage
c'était un état où enfin quelque chose
se refroidissait et et quand son quand
son amant meurt 2 jours enfin 2 jours
avant le vernissage en 71 ça aurait dû
être le plus beau jour de de la vie
artistique de bacon quand même être
célébré au Grand Palais en grande pompe
avec les gardes républicains avec George
Pompidou il y a que Picasso qui a v eu
ça de son vivant bah c'est aussi son
plus grand malheur son qu'il a peint 80
fois et dans cet expo 500 tableau en
tout il a fait 500 tableaux dans 500
tableaux de Baccon 80 portraits de
George d'Er et dans cette exposition il
y avait George d'Er partout et il entre
avec Pompidou et il voit partout le
corps de son amant qui est seul dans une
chambre tout nu sur sur les toilettes
mort comment faites-vous Miguel
qu'est-ce qui vous pousse à faire soit
de la gravure soit de la sculpture parce
que vous sculptez aussi soit de la
peinture soit tout on retrouve dans les
différents ateliers avec des pigments
sont des pigments originels et pas des
des des couleurs construites moi ce que
j'aime plus c'est de pas savoir ce que
je vais faire dans la journée quand je
me lève j'aime beaucoup vaguer et
attraper quelque chose que ça peut être
une céramique ou une gravure ou une
vitthographie ou un carnet j'ai toujours
des carnets où je quelqu fois j'écris
mais la plupart de temps je fais des
aquarelles quelques fois c'est aqu pour
un projet de livre comme j'ai fais la
métamorphose de Kafka où je fais
maintenant un Bor re hum imaginaire que
je finirai un jour ou un tableau mais
après quand je quand je commence je
continue vers mais j'aime beaucoup de
pas avoir un projet j'aime bien de
d'aller privilègeoup et vous et vous
reprenez beaucoup les es oui j'aime bien
d'eacer effacer et et recommencer c'est
un peu aussi h tout table une espèce de
Pasin sur d'autres choses c'est rare que
ça marche d'un premier coup j'ai pensais
à bacon et j'ai pensais à Jackson
Pollock Jackson Pollock travaillait
comme ça il se préparit temp et puis et
puis entrit en peinture quand il était
prêt souvent après de semaines de
salerie après il ne buvait pas quand il
peignait mais il avait bu beaucoup avant
mais moi je fais pas ça je fais je je
vis dans cette dans la céramique la
peinture pendant de périodes je me sou
après mais mais pas pendant alors c'est
la question que je vous pose à tous les
deux c'est le rapport qui existe entre
le cinéma et la peinture au fond
beaucoup de cinéastes ont le complexe de
la peinture où on voit par qu cubri dans
Barry lindol le début c'est un gamesbor
comment vous avez l'un et l'autre
réfléchi à ça c'est le cinéma et la
peinture dans le cinéma il y a Godar
aussi qu'on voit quasiment peindre à la
fin de sa vie dans dans les derniers
films expérimentaux c'est très beau il
essaie de trouver des choses moi je
dirais même cinéma peinture littérature
moi j'adorerais savoir peindre c'est
évidemment parce que je ne sais pas
peindre vous avvez essayé avec la torche
j'ai essayé dans la nuit mais il restait
rien quoi une fois qu'on allume les
lumière il y a il y a il y a y a une
passion physique enfin que j'admire chez
les peintres la la représentation pour
moi elle elle a lieu sur tous les plans
et j'aime que dans le livre de Miguel il
y ait les mots il y a des listes
merveilleuses des listes de poètes et et
et quand j'écris je vois en couleur je
vois tout en couleur je vois les phrases
qui flambois enfin j'essaie de faire de
la peinture en écrivant voilà des romans
bacon parlait justement de l'influence
de buuel qui était pour lui beaucoup
plus importante que celle de l'histoire
de la peinture sur son propre travail
est-ce que vous avez quel est le rapport
que vous avez avec le cinéma moi je par
Céma c'est une forme de peinture tu sais
le cinéma c'était un art indépendant au
20e siècle au 19e et 20e siècle quand
par c'était un art nouveau un art qui
avait une technique nouvelle mais je
pense que cinématographie lthographie
cérigraphie tout ça c'est technique
picturale mais c'est une forme de
fabriquer des images qui bougent pas ou
SCO c'est la même c'est la même chose
avec un peu de perspective c'est pareil
c'est la même chose surtout après les
Digital quion pe ce n'est plus de
documents du réel parce qu'on pouvez
croire que ça c'est maintenant c'est
c'est un fruit de l'esprit comme non
alors c'est pareil voilà Miguel Barcelo
donc c'est de la vida Mia c'est un livre
extraordinairement riche avec vous le
voyez des carnets des textes des photos
de l'atelier des photos Mali du côté de
Gao des des photos des tableaux
d'aujourd'hui et donc c'est tenue au
Musée mais la carrière de Yannick ne
s'arrête pas à cette nuit au musée vous
pouvez retrouver tous ces livres
trésorier payeur euh le dernier si ma
mémoire est bonne je vous suggère de
lire ainsi parler à natle France d'abord
parce qu'il a été euh pris Nobel de
littérature après tout euh c'est une
chose qui n'est pas négligeable dit et
Maxime deve choisi présenté par
Guillaume metteyer c'est dans un chez un
éditeur qui s'appelle arfen à HLE France
qui a travaillé pour le Sénat NAT France
qu'on vouscouvrirz là les aphorismes euh
qui reste particulièrement actuel merci
à tous les deux on sent qu'il y a quand
même une sorte d'amitié qui vous lit
même si vous voyez pas très souvent donc
tant mieux grâce à cette émission vous
allez vous voir plus
souvent merci merci Yannick et à bientôt
surtout
[Musique]
merci c'était au bonheur des livres avec
le Centre national du
livre